presentation is about
ziki ziki is a ui language
a language for creating user interfaces
i'm craig youth i've been involving ziki
for about 10 years
you can go to ziki.org to download and
install ziki what do you think the
simplest possible way
of creating a user interface is it's an
interesting question isn't it
the simplest possible way to create a ui
what do you think it is i would argue
there really aren't any
really simple ways of creating a ui and
that there should be
that's kind of what this presentation is
is all about
uis are very important not just the uis
that we create for our end users
but the uis we create for ourselves and
for other
developers uh they're also very
important
and uh kind of undervalued in my opinion
i'm going to do two things in this
presentation i'm going to do a lot of
awesome ziki demos
number one and number two i'm going to
try to convince you
that the time has come for a lightweight
ui language a language that makes it
really simple to create uis
a language that is very generic so it
can bring together
these existing ui paradigms
and what i mean by that is the uis you
make with this language
without a whole lot of extra coding
should be usable
as web uis command line uis mobile uis
desktop uis
these are some pretty ambitious goals
so zuki probably shouldn't try to
solve all ui problems it should probably
focus in on one thing and do it really
well
and what ziki focuses in on is nested
menus if you analyze most uis
they boil down to nested lists of
choices
you've got a list of options you click
on one and you see another list
presented in various forms
ziki tries really hard to utilize
existing languages and tools to let them
solve
some of the problems of uis
the three things that you get when you
install ziki are a web server
a ziki shell command and editor plugins
the web server and the editor both
delegate to the ziki
shell command so ziki
the shell command is at the core of the
language which is how things are with
most languages
when people think up new user interfaces
they sometimes go to a whiteboard and
write out an outline let's say you're
making up a
mobile ui for plane flights you might go
to a whiteboard and
write out book flight check in
flight status and indented underneath
book flight you might put one way
and round trip you might wipe it out you
might write out an outline
like this one a simple indented outline
of the items in your ui
why can't that be a language for
creating user interfaces
where you just type out an indented
outline of the items
really that's all the information you
need to create a working ui why can't it
be that simple
here is a mobile interface
being dynamically rendered from this
outline
actually from this text file which
is a text version of the outline
the only difference is that there are
slashes
at the end that syntax is inspired by
urls and paths
they sort of make these lines behave
like directories
you can we can edit this file here
and save and refresh over here to verify
that this is being backed by this
uh this file this is the uh ziki
language i'll refresh and make it go
away for now
you can see that it's showing the
unindented items first
book flights check in and flight status
and as you might guess when you click on
book flight it's going to show you one
way in round trip
because they're indented underneath
with most frameworks even the more
compact ui and
web frameworks making a simple ui like
this can take multiple files
many lines of code and boilerplate often
in multiple languages even with gui
tools
there can be a lot of clicking and
dragging and typing stuff involved to
make a simple ui like this
i say it should be doable in one file
and five lines
if it's simple it should exist
right what would it take a a language
like this to be really useful
let's uh try adding a couple things to
uh to our file here
let's add an about item at the top
and underneath it let's put um
let's put uh
strange loop flights
and um if i refresh that you can see the
item shows up but i can drill into it
and since i didn't put a slash at the
end it shows that it's plain text
you can add a heading by using a
greater than i'll say summary so if we
refresh this
you can see the summaries there
you can go down here and add dynamic
behavior using an exclamation mark
i'll say 2 times 200 and if we go to
this round trip item we'll see that it
runs the code
book flight round trip and shows the
output this is ruby code
by default but it can also be other
types of code
um since this is just running on
uh localhost colon8161 we can open it in
a
a web browser um
so let's do that let's open it in a
normal web browser
um
this uh web browser is
a uh uh uh
this web server is a little server that
comes with ziki
that renders files like these as mobile
menus
there's also a rails plugin that will
let rails apps do this
and other web frameworks can shell out
to the ziki
shell command to to do this
um one thing the web has taught us
about ui is urls are very useful
it's really convenient for users to be
able to jump to specific parts of your
app
so it probably makes sense for a simple
ui language like this to have urls built
into it so they can do things like paths
if we go in and look at the url
as we click on these items you can see
that it adds
what we click on to the the url if we
click on book flight
it'll add it to the url if we click on
round trip it'll add it
just like web servers do with
directories except in our case
everything is just in one file
okay uh if all
a language did was rendered files in a
web browser as a mobile interface
that wouldn't be uh really really useful
um let me actually try to
close this and bring it up again uh
i don't know why it was showing it as a
different
text size it's just a text file um
this web server is kind of cool even
though it's simple because
uh if you drop a ziki plug-in into your
web app
that means uh even non-techie users
can go to urls that don't exist and
i'll go to car rentals and they'll be
prompted to make menus and they
contribute
they can contribute uis to your app
let's make avis and rent a car
and put a heading underneath it
so you can add uh uis to an actual app
and then the developers can link to them
even ajax to them to use it in their app
but if you think about it this outline
style
isn't limited to just uh
mobile really it can apply to all of
these
uh all of these paradigms all these ui
paradigms
so we've seen uh accessing our flights
menu with mobile and then we've accessed
the mobile interface
through the web app how about the other
ones how about command line what would
that look like
let's bring up a terminal
and uh i'll type ziki which is the
main shell command that comes with ziki
and i can put flights after it
and we can navigate our flights menu on
the command line
if we add something to the end of the
path
i can hit return and it will drill in
and show the options
how about uh gui
is this how about
accessing our flights menu with a
desktop
gui rather what would that look like
here is a very simple desktop ui
that is going to read in our flight file
and render the ui as a desktop interface
book flight round trip
how about voice
here's a really simple script
that is going to
present using voice uh the same menu
for about press one for book flight
press two
for check-in press three for flight
status press 4.
it's pretty obvious right it's just
reading in and displaying the unintended
item for one way press one for round
trip
press two and of course you could make
that into a
voice recognition interface pretty
easily with a pretty small step
how about this last one this text ui
paradigm that's been floating around
here
what's that all about text as a ui
paradigm that's kind of what
most of the rest of the presentation is
about
as i mentioned earlier i think the
uis that we developers make for
ourselves and for other developers
are very important so how could a
language
like this be used to help out
developers developers use
interfaces that are very close to the
metal they run shell commands
they um they run
code they search in files they navigate
files
they're not going to click around in a
little mobile interface
but uh you can sort of see how you could
do things
that users techie users developers can
use as well file paths the path to this
would be users
craigslist shoppinglists.txt it's fairly
obvious
for sql and other languages developers
use the path to these
rows would be select star from users
slash and then this row
that seems kind of weird but i think
it'll
make more sense in a moment here
so here is a plain text file on my
desktop
you can see it's just a txt file which
is about the simplest kind of file there
is
i'm going to double click on it to open
in a text editor and then
delete the contents so we can type some
stuff
um fortunately most of the text editors
and ides
that people use these days are
extendable
uh which is where the ziki text editor
plug-in
comes in
let's start with a couple of examples of
how this might work let's
start with two examples that you're
probably familiar with
typing urls and double-clicking
or clicking to view them in the
web browser let's go uh loc since i'm
not connected to the internet
so you've probably all seen apps that
let you do this
a lot of email clients let you do this
click on the url once it's been typed
since the ziki plugin is enabled we can
double-click on any line
and it will open up the url in the
browser
you can also do control return by
default if you prefer keyboard shortcuts
and all this text editor plugin is doing
is shelling out to uh the ziki shell
command not surprisingly
and passing in uh whatever the user
clicks on
so let me paste that there and you can
see it does the same thing
so how about another example how about
uh sql statements you've probably all
seen
gui tools sql gui tools that let you
type sql statements
and double click to run them uh the text
editor plug-in is going to work the same
way it's going to just shell out to the
ziki shell command
past that line and this time there's
output that we need to display to the
user
so how should we do that how about a
really
simple uh lowest common denominator
solution
so that we can make uh plugins for other
editors and ides pretty easily
how about we just insert the results
underneath and then to two spaces
which you can see is is what ziki does
this makes some of the other challenges
uh
of ui easier to do so far everything
we've done has been read-only
so we should probably start thinking
about our uh creating and our
updating strategy and maybe some of that
will spill back over to some of the
other ui paradigms
so once you've got the text in here in
your text editor everything is plain
text
so the obvious way to edit is just to
edit inline
and then double click or control enter
to save back to the database
and we can collapse and we can see that
the change took effect
and the creating strategy comes becomes
pretty uh pretty obvious too
you can either just type something in or
you can
start with an initial record
and make a new one
and double click to save it back and if
we collapse
uh we can see that it created the record
this isn't
as elegant in a lot of ways as a
full-fledged gui sql tool
that will let you know click on the
column titles to sort
but in other ways it is pretty elegant
let's say
you want to make a change to a record
but you're not absolutely positive about
it
if you've got text you can just copy and
paste to make a
version and you can update and if you
didn't like it you can just roll back by
launching that
that's really clunky to do in a gui
so you can start to see how the editing
paradigm in ziki works
you just uh edit whatever you got
out you just change it and send it back
to ziki
and the other editing pair the other ui
paradigms can do the same thing they can
read and
modify and just just write back to the
url
undo is also kind of cool to have in the
context of uis like this
all right everything i've shown you so
far has been black and white to make it
clear that everything is text
but there is uh optional formatting
i'm going to change the background to
black and i went into a presentation
mode
which is a uh editor-specific feature so
i won't go into it i'm going to focus on
the
the general stuff uh it turns out
you can type all kinds of things that
developers
uh like to use if you want to see what
your ip is you can just type ip and
double click on it
that's just shelling out to the ziki
shell command
code you can type code this is ruby code
but you can also type
javascript code if it looks like
javascript it'll run as javascript you
can just double click on it
or ctrl enter shell commands just begin
the
line with a dollar sign and it runs it
as a shell command
directories you can just type a
directory double click
let's narrow down to the foo project if
the menu outputs
pluses and minuses uh they behave as
optional bullet points
so you can use the mouse to drill in
just like you do a normal gui file tree
if you drill into a source file will
show you the methods
you can double click to navigate to the
file
if you want to run a shell command in a
specific directory you can combine these
syntaxes together
you just indent the shell command two
spaces underneath the directory
everything is still plain text by the
way i can turn off the formatting to
show you
so if i double click on that it'll run
that shell command in that directory
if you want to run async commands use a
percent
if you want to have item for example run
something
use an ampersand so this is an example
of ziki utilizing other tools
to to handle some of the ui challenges
you can show all files and type to
narrow down i just typed rb to narrow
down to all the
ruby files this hash syntax will search
so let's search for def space and all
the source files
and i can type to narrow down this is
going to search for
install star star will search for file
names
you can map searches and everything else
to keyboard shortcuts
so i'm going to search for food in the
ziki directory uh
using a keyboard shortcut editing or
creating files how do you think that
works
probably just edit inline right
edit the output so if you want to
comment out a gem
you can expand the file and
update it inline and you can see that it
changed
and if that file didn't exist
it would create it
okay here is a example of
a ui working with a web browser
a text ui working with a
a web browser to create a gui ui this is
kind of like on the wii
when you choose your character
um it's going through picking options uh
unicorn hair is the coolest hair option
clearly you can type address book and it
will
delegate to the mac address book app
you can type itunes to control itunes
[Music]
pause play go into your songs
uh piano you can make up your own
sounds and it will send the notes to a
mini device uh this
this nested plain text environment is
really nice for making up your own
dsls this is a dsl for randomizing music
notes in a really simple way
when it gets to the end it re-runs the
stuff at the bottom
it's changing the key change in between
each changing the tempo
if you make a song that you like you can
just indent it
underneath a string
with a slash at the end and then save it
and then later on if you want to listen
to it
you can type the name of your string
anywhere and bring it back up
this editor is aquamax by the way which
is a very user-friendly
version of emacs here is vim
vim isn't fully supported but you can do
basic stuff
go into insert mode type sql statement
and control return to show the output
lot of people want
vim support more full vim support and
ziki
and i definitely want to do that i'm
looking for people that are willing to
pair with me on it
here is a code mirror prototype
so if you let you edit stuff in the
browser it's very limited but you can do
headings and here's a prototype
of control enter
sublime uh third party uh wrote a
sublime plugin
all right the reason ziki has all these
examples
is because and all these syntaxes you
can type is because it's really easy to
create
syntaxes um
as i mentioned in your home directory
there's a menu directory here all my
custom directories uh and files to make
menus
in the ziki directory itself there's a
menu directory that has all the
menus that come with ziki there are a
lot of them
uh if a language wants to be ui focused
it should probably have
the best hello world experience um the
hello world and ziki is you just make a
txt file in a directory and that's it so
let's make a hello
file let's edit it and say hi
loop save it and now i can type
hello and use it from a text editor if
you have a ziki plugin installed
i can run it on the command line here
let's have i term
run this command just do ziki and then
the name of your file
you can run it in the web browser
uh just by going to localhost 8161
and then slash whatever the name of your
file was
uh by the way the uh eight one six one
is the port because uh
the way i style it it uh looks kind of
like
x i ki the way i style the logo
the shark is kind of helping to make the
k look like a six
it's kind of kind of a stretch but makes
it easier to remember
okay so another hello world if you're in
a text editor and you know your file is
going to be a
txt you can just type the name of your
file.txt
it'll give you a little example and then
you can just double click to create it
and you can type a and double click to
use it
it can also be a dot rb file let's just
use their
use the default it can also be a
js file bootstrap this one's kind of
cool
if you just type something that
bootstrap it'll give you a
example bootstrap dsl layout
and then you can view that in the web
browser let's go uh
update this you can see it uh
change it's randomizing the colors just
to give you some ideas
what you might want to look like dot
menu is the default
ziki language
two-space indenting format
you can also make menus inline
so if this menu didn't exist yet i can
just type it out and type the keyboard
shortcut and then immediately go in and
start using it
that brings the language over into the
realm of
an interactive language but there's no
need for a rebel
you can just type things out and
immediately start using them
let's uh let's make up a new ui for
snitter which is a
which is twitter for snakes
an idea whose time has clearly come
let's uh
type out a few options sign in
and uh it's neat i don't know it's
horrible
hiss times two sorry i apologize for
these examples they're horrible
so i can type the keyboard shortcut and
then i can immediately start using the
ui
i just created and of course you can
view all these in the web browser
and start using them
you can type keyboard shortcuts to jump
to the source of any file
that you're that you're using any menu
you're using
you can uh define menus inline
this will make it so that if you click
on a line says hi it'll run the block
every sort of simple way of making uis i
tried to work in here so if you try
something you think like
hey maybe this will work chances are it
might work this is a regular expression
if a line begins with aaa
it'll run the block uh there are many
ways of of
making menus this is how you
programmatically run a menu the dot
expand method
is the same as the brackets it's kind of
at the core of the the language
if you use it directly um through ruby
um these are defining keyboard shortcuts
this one here will um
make control d control s show this uh
table and then of course you can edit it
and do everything else it pops up in a
new view
this is a dead simple ruby class
with methods and if we
create that it will use the methods as
the
first level of menus and it will run
them when you expand them
if you don't know how to make a menu a
certain way
you can just type it out double click
it'll say hey it doesn't exist yet and
it will give you
a bunch of options of different ways you
can make things in code there are a lot
of kind of sophisticated
oo options for merging
declared menus with classes and doing
routing to
to map some of the items to to classes
here's a menu that's a directory
you can just type a dire and the files
in the directory
will be the menu items and when you
expand them it'll
it'll run the files here's an
example of a very simple dynamic menu
here it is right here let me create it
and if i expand this it will show tables
i can type to narrow down because ziki
does that by default
and i can go in and view the tables
so this menu here is implemented
completely
by this file which has just these two
lines
uh this first line says if there isn't
an argument passed in
uh just show all the tables the second
one says else
uh do a select star so it's kind of the
thinnest possible way of making
a little ui on top of a lot of tools
all right so using ziki as a web
development tool
how would that work if you want to try
out some html
you can just type html gives you a
little example
and you can edit it double click again
to see it updates you don't even have to
know html you can just type it
css you can just type css and it will
give you some default css
you can change it so if you don't know
css it's a really
quick way of learning at javascript you
can type javascript run some stuff in
the browser
if you prefer coffee you can type coffee
uh and it runs that in the browser
so the idea here as you can kind of see
probably is you should be able to type
any word
that you think a web developer would
want to use
bootstrap you can type
bootstrap and type a little dsl that we
saw earlier
greater than for headings it'll render
it in the
browser when you double click going to
make a
couple paragraphs by default if you
sandwich them together
they'll be columns but if you make them
separate
separated by a blank line it'll make
them in separate rows
you can do the cool bootstrap
multi-column stuff
by adding blank lines in certain places
uh then you can drill into the bootstrap
menu to see other examples
dom let's bring up this uh bootstrap app
and uh type dom and then we can drill
into the dom
to to go in and mess with stuff
let's go and edit this h1
you can see the change happened over
here in the browser
if you know the id of an element you can
just type
the id directly with a pound and it will
expand it out you can see it's blinking
it
and we can go edit it this way
and update it if you don't know the ids
you can
just type ids and it will expand out
and show you all your your ids you can
search in the dom by this
hash syntax so that found
found this line here and you can expand
it out
and edit that rails this
r menu here lets you run code inside of
the context of a rails app
like a rails console
if you do something that returns active
record objects
it will recognize that and let you
edit and double-click to save back so we
can expand again to see that it
saved the change you can interact with
request headers
models you can just type models so kind
of any word that you think
you should be able to type give it a try
see if it works it might redirect you to
another place if it doesn't work
so here are the models in my app i can
type to drill in
and it gives me a few options this at
just means ignore everything else and
run this in isolation
so we can go and type alligator.new and
it'll give us the blank
yaml we can create a record
uh just by editing the blank game and
double clicking and it will save it back
to create the record
so we can do a dot last and we can see
that it just created our record
this is a really nice and kind of a cool
way of of
interacting with the rails app it's
slicker than a rails console in a lot of
ways
you could make a the same menu for for
node just by embedding a controller and
node
here is expanding out a rails menu
underneath a rails app
you can make new resources
etc it'll give you or controllers
it'll give you default values that you
can just pick from
markdown here is uh some markdown uh
code
that you can just edit to try out hamel
here's some hamel uh node
here is a node controller
we can just edit and double click again
and it will run the uh restart the
server and run the controller
so if you want to get started with a
tool like node and you have ziki
typing the name of the tool and then
just editing the examples
i think is the fastest possible way of
getting started
with a new tool you can you know search
on the website and get
running in a few minutes this is
literally like 15 seconds you've got a
working example backbone
uh here is the rails plug and i
mentioned earlier here's a rails app
and if i go to a url that doesn't exist
the ziki plugin
will prompt me to make make uis
in the context of that app all right so
i've got
other screencasts you can find in the
web and my rubyconf talk
went into a lot of detail about how you
can use ziki as a
shell console replacement
it's really slick um shell consoles
haven't changed much in 40 years
um you can here i'll show you a couple
things you can here's a
keyboard shortcut that will search for
recent commands in a specific directory
and then you can type to narrow down
to rerun commands that in itself is is
really useful
uh most shell commands will show you all
the
recent uh most most shells will show the
recent commands run in all directories
um you can make
notes that you wrap around the
shell commands that you type in text
files and then you can share those text
files with other people and they can
use the the command so you're sort of
making a little documentation
ui that's interactive um
you can run remote shell commands and
edit remote files you can wrap uh
little uis around shell commands to make
them a little easier to use
chmod if you don't remember what they
are you can just indent it underneath
your file
and then it gives you default options so
you can just click on to run
okay ziki is a note taking tool you can
make text files full of notes with
greater than
for headings like this one and
then you can type keyboard shortcuts to
uh see an outline of your notes and then
type to narrow down
so here are my ruby notes here's my md5
node i can
jump to it and then run the code here's
the output
when you're in a file that has notes you
can type a keyboard shortcut to show all
of the
uh headings in that file and type to
narrow down and then
jump to the section you can
add interactive memorizing two notes in
your file this is inspired by
memrise.com which is another one of my
projects
so if you double click on this it gives
you a little interactive
memorizing mode where you can
memorize the notes that you create
ziki has an ide
you can uh split your text cellular
windows
and have a file tree down here that you
can use just like a gui
file tree but it's all text so you can
edit the stuff that you don't care about
delete add notes in your file tree fix
this on the top left i usually
put shell commands and things i interact
with
here is a keyboard shortcut that shows
all the methods in my project and i can
type to narrow down
here is a little menu that i created for
a sample app
that i can use to do standard common
things like browse it
in the web browser run the unit tests
run common rake tasks
if you're a new developer and you come
on to a team and you have a little menu
like this you can just type
it's a way better experience than people
saying like oh yeah you have to type all
these commands and hear the rake tasks
why shouldn't we make developers like
uis like this for developers that come
onto our teams
git here is a visualization of all the
get changes i need to make
you can commit files together
phone call
unit tests you can drill in and run unit
tests inline
and if there's an error you can jump to
the error
you can browse ziki jams you can edit
[ __ ] if you forget where apache config
files are
you can type apache uh
just a couple quick examples of uh using
ziki as a rapid prototyping tool here's
a little ui
that has a mobile interface like we've
seen and
if you drill into some of the items they
have
bootstrap displays of the individual
menu items which is
which is really easy to do
um let's see skip this stuff d3
svg 3js uh as
more people start using and contributing
to ziki uh people are contributing more
of these menus
so eventually you know hopefully every
every word that you would think of to
type
will either do something that you would
expect it to or
uh send you in the right direction
here's a cool uh
shoes uh example that's pulled from the
shoes
website uh all right who won the battle
between gui and text there's been this
battle going on for
for decades on two fronts
the end user and the developer tools
gui largely has won the end user battle
but development tools
are still dominated by text the files
that we
create in our projects are just text
files we have access to them we don't
have to go through some
gui that encapsulates the files why is
that why is text still going strong
in the development community new
projects like rails and node they're
texts first there's absolutely no gui
and then
people add on gooeys after the fact to
augment them
uh wiki's twitter is using text as part
of their ui
you can just type at or pound
as a user you don't have to press a
button
facebook recently adopted this and uh
with wikipedia
uh being very text heavy that's three of
the top
ten websites that have text as a very uh
integral part of their their ui so what
we didn't foresee
i think a couple decades ago when we
thought gooey was going to take over all
development tools
is that developing
languages and texts was going to
continue to improve as well
and the the small set of formats like
html xml and json
those in my opinion are a big part of
what has made our lives as developers
easy and better over the last few years
the future of ui is largely going to be
voice recognition
which changes the the relationship uh
users are now going to say like hey i
told my app
to do something and didn't know how to
do it instead of saying like don't give
me too many options
so we're gonna have to start engaging in
these textual conversations with our
users
uh okay that's that's just about it if
you're if you like where ziki is going
there's a get tip button
on ziki.org please consider donating i'm
keeping my eye out for sponsor companies
i'd probably open to adding a menu for
your tool
in the korazinki distribution i think if
i'm transparent about that
users won't mind i think
pair programming is the future of how
all of us
developers are going to connect with
each other uh follow me
as ziki on twitter and tweet
and we'll hook up and we'll do a pairing
session um
there's no commitment i'm not looking
for contributors i'm just looking for
people to pair
for me with one hour i've done like 30
of them they've all been great i've done
remote and local sessions
um i'll find something that is fun for
you to work on and
i promise i'll keep it fun and that's
all i got thanks a lot